all right Garrett hi Garrett uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally so I grew up in Indiana it's
called Monrovia no one knows where it is
basically in the middle of a cornfields
and uh tell me about your family
so I'm an only child
um I was raised Pentecostal
um and obviously compared to what I've
transformed myself into definitely
doesn't align with how I was raised and
it's been a journey do you think what
you're doing now is a reaction to
to that upbringing
um I always get that statement that
people look at me and they're like oh
you do this or you're in this lifestyle
because of
trauma like growing up but that's
definitely I feel like not the case
um I don't know I feel like I've always
just done what I've wanted to and even
if I had like a perfect you know
childhood I feel like I'd still be a
little a little Barbie doll would you
say you were born this way yeah for sure
yeah it wasn't like there was some
traumatic
I mean besides like I mean so let's just
go all the way back so I only child
raised Pentecostal
um everything was fine up until about
um 15 16
now it's not even that taboo of a thing
but obviously my family was like we
think you're gay and
um
they sent me to conversion counseling at
16 which happened to also be the age I
started getting into escorting because I
just knew I needed to get out of the
house and I needed to make money fast
and that was kind of my way of doing so
and at 17 I I actually got emancipated
um and that was all thanks to being a
sugar baby and being financially stable
for myself tell me about conversion
counseling that sounds interesting yeah
so it wasn't like a camp
where like I feel like a lot of people
don't convert you from being gay to
straight oh yeah for sure
um you know very religious oriented um
I'd go we'd read scriptures there were
also other kids there
um it was never like a camp I stayed at
it was always Monday through Friday
every day after school and then Saturday
was youth group Sunday was you know the
Sunday service sometimes we go to church
on Wednesday nights mixing Bible studies
in there like my entire childhood was
really just like church and what are
they trying to teach you or put in your
head dofling praying the gay away was
like basically the best way to explain
it like
um you know you're gonna burn in hell
this is kind of like you know obviously
it's wrong to think these things feel
this way
um yeah just a lot of reading and just
they wanted you to self-reflect a lot
um and of course just being told that
you know you're gonna burn in hell one
day or something to a 15 year old that's
really traumatic so you weren't having
it no and I feel like that's why I I
don't know I just really I guess like
the doll or just the whole plastic
aesthetic because it was just to me this
like perfect world and that was kind of
my way I guess of coping with everything
that was going on so you mentioned
earlier so you kind of envisioned
yourself as a
yeah I envisioned myself as like I call
myself the Sugar Baby Ken doll because I
feel like I look a little bit like well
a lot like kind of in the face and then
my body is definitely very like Barbie
um I don't know I just love big lips
I've had button plants if I had a
rhinoplasty filler filler filler kybella
I've had a lot of work done how old are
you I'm 21 now you're 21. you've got a
lot of work done yeah I have
and so you moved to LA
uh when I was 18. 18. yeah but I got
emancipated from my parents at 17 I
lived with the sugar daddy I had met all
the way you know in my younger days
um until I was just like you know I I
can't even stay in Indiana anymore it's
just not worth it so tell me how being a
sugar baby
has played out for you
um I mean definitely I feel like looking
back starting at like 15 16
um basically selling my body for money
sneaking out of the house and sleeping
with men in their 40s 50s even 60s
um like it was you know obviously
looking back I feel a little different
about it but my life is great now
um I've definitely set myself up
financially for a good while I also
don't really like to work so I I don't
know I just enjoy I know I enjoy my life
and people say I'm gonna have severe
trauma when I'm older but like I I don't
know I kind of love it because also
people
I think
look so so definitely when I started out
it was definitely just escorting now I
consider myself a sugar baby because
it's much different I have you know
solid men that I'm building an emotional
connection with
some of them are like really high
profile people that I've had to sign
ndas for some of them are just the most
random people and I don't know you're
kind of helping them because you
specifically one of my sugar daddies
he's
literally 70 and he's I don't know he
everyone in his life has kind of passed
away around him and it is kind of sad to
kind of know that he is very lonely and
like I don't know I well I'm glad his
bank account is big I don't know if I'd
be there but um if it wasn't for that
but I do like I don't know I enjoy it
like kind of being there emotionally for
people if that makes sense have you been
in love before
I've been in love but I definitely don't
ever want to fall in love with the sugar
daddy romantically
um I don't know I feel like in a way
that's kind of I mean I get if you're
attracted to like older people but I
kind of feel like if I'm like settling
down with someone much older than me
it's kind of wasting my youth away if
that makes sense like I want to be young
and look forward to dating and falling
in love with you know young people you
know my age so and you're making good
money doing this yes I'm making very
good money um literally there's an
article out as soon as I turn 21 I not
liquid cash but I with all my assets I
have you know it's in the millions
within like properties I have and cars
bags you know I've definitely saved a
lot of you know the money and that's all
generated from being a sugar baby yes
and only fans but yeah so basically just
all the sex work so how does how does
being a sex object effect
how do you
how do you feel about that
you seem pretty comfortable with it yeah
I'm very comfortable in it
um again it's so hard for people to
grasp which is kind of
I don't know it's so weird to me because
I get people view sex very differently
but to me like
it is like an intimate thing but I don't
look at sex like as this like like we
should just shun it away or like not
talk about it not be very expressive
with it
um I don't know I love sex and if I can
make a bag doing it why not you know so
I think a lot of women feel the same way
yeah for sure I feel like people are
also really scared to get into that
industry
um
and again it's very dangerous don't get
me wrong I've put myself in many
uncomfortable unsafe situations
um
that have been really bad for me but for
the most part you know it's been a very
successful Journey you mentioned earlier
that uh you might somebody someone said
you might be getting PTSD from what
you're doing but yeah explain how that
would be
um
I don't know because I'm not feel like
I'm experiencing it but I definitely
have
you know comments that are always like
oh he's going to be traumatized when
he's older he's gonna and since I am
very public
um about being a sugar baby I mean it's
literally my entire life and brand
online like I just it's my I'm sure you
get more than your share of judgment
right exactly which also benefits me in
the fact that I don't have to actively
seek out people like people will reach
out to me like hey I'm looking for a
sugar baby or let's go on a date
show me proof of funds
um but yeah I don't know I I feel like
it's not traumatizing me right now
um I do look back at being you know like
15 and 16 and it was a little bit like
it's just sad in the sense that I was
doing that just to escape you know the
situation I was in growing up and I was
never physically abused
um
but again my parents
their way of showing love in a way was
money it wasn't you know Personal Touch
or
I guess like one-on-one time because my
dad worked a lot so I kind of my mindset
in life has always been money and I kind
of feel like
um in a way
my parents just kind of like giving me
money and just like you go to the side
was kind of just their way of like not
having to deal with me and I say deal
with me but I know me being gay and
stuff like that and very feminine it
just I mean we don't have a relationship
now so you don't even talk to your
family no
and coming from Southern Southern
Indiana I would think it's a
hard thing for them to accept right for
sure and also as I'm their only child
it's kind of like well I have no no
other kids left you know so it's
but again that's why I'm I'm a hustler I
I'm all about money I've created a great
life for myself you know not a lot of 21
year olds can say they've they're a
millionaire so like it's I don't know
it's something I'm definitely proud of
so and I think also that's something I
think about too maybe I would feel like
I have more PTSD and more Trauma from
this industry if I wasn't making as much
money but since I kind of I know like
material things are everything but I
feel like if it wasn't for the my
material things I wouldn't be as proud
and open of being a sugar baby if that
makes sense because right now I'm not
like being a sugar baby to get by like
if I quit today like I'd be fine for
like a while
um so yeah but give me an example of
what would be trauma inducing
trauma causing
um
well this was a little crazy but again I
got paid for it so it was fine but like
I mean
back when I had oh God back when I first
moved to LA
um
he's a very public figure signed an NDA
um it's so great I don't even know if I
want to say this but like I've you know
give people all of their
fetish desires like I don't know the
word I like
um
bring them into fruition I guess um like
I've [ __ ] on people before for well many
times but it's always a good price tag
like the first guy ever stood on it was
ten thousand dollars
um P everything like you name the Kink
and also it is kind of fascinating too
to like
I don't know understand people's Kings
like and not in all cases but I do find
that the wealthier the person the more
like
kinky they are I don't know just or
maybe that's they just expect more
um that could kind of be traumatic to
someone but again like me
I'm just I think it's kind of funny at
this point like I don't know like people
take a [ __ ] for free like I think I said
for like ten thousand dollars so it
could be worse
do you feel like being a you're
basically a sex toy to a lot of your
your clients yeah for sure but do you
feel like you're attracting this you're
whatever you want to call it is is it
commodity yeah that you can you can milk
right yeah exactly and also I feel like
it kind of I'm sure women a lot of
attractive women feel that way oh yeah
for sure and I also
um I don't know like it is me and like
I've never like pretending to be someone
else but it is almost like a character
you know like I'll get dressed up
sometimes like obviously I have a very
feminine appearance and then if I'm
super dressed down I can have like a
very you know masculine young boy as
look aesthetic which is what a lot of
guys want too so like I can kind of play
both roles which is fun
um so yeah like sometimes I'll be
dressed up in a full like Barbie wig
sometimes I'll just be like fully
stripped down
and
um yeah it's I don't know it's like a
character I get to put on and I think
that kind of
helps because I'm a very like visual
person and I just love everything in my
life to just be like aesthetically
pleasing and I don't know I just feel
like it makes me seem more like a doll
it's like a little character I get to
play
and it's my job
and how does this impact you emotionally
do you get anxious depressed angry
anything like that I mean I definitely
like
there's been a few times I've been like
scammed or played and that really it's
that it just like makes me second guess
like everything I just did
um but no I've never been on like any
antidepressants
um again I'm like very proud of what I
do but I I do I feel like
um I drink a lot especially for someone
my size and like 100 pounds people are
like damn like you're 100 pounds how
much how tall are you uh six foot you're
six feet 100 pounds yeah wow
um
and yeah I do drink a lot and I feel
like but it's never out of like me being
sad or to like cope emotionally it's
more just like
definitely I love to be buzzed when I'm
meeting a client it just makes things go
better and easier
um even with sugar daddies like of
course with some of my sugar daddies
like we'll go on trips and
I've been flown literally all over the
world but
um
yeah it's never like to cope with
anything I just and I also make so much
money
sometimes in my head I'm like oh well
I'm not an alcoholic because I'm making
money and I'm like you know I'm doing
you know everything also my dogs are my
everything I have four dogs and I think
emotionally they help me a lot too my
four little pugs it doesn't seem like
it's that terrible lifestyle for you you
seem pretty comfortable with the whole
thing yeah I am and again it sounds
pretty fun it is fun I mean yeah and
it's also crazy again like I've signed
so many ndas because there's people on
TV there's singers that I've met and
it's
um
it's just it's just funny to me because
this is stuff I'm you know besides my
really close friends I'm gonna have to
like basically take to my grave or my
tell-all book way in the future
um but yeah no I have a crazy iconic
life and one of my big Inspirations is
like Paris Hilton
I love my tracksuits I love my like Y2K
little Range Rovers and cars I just love
that era of pop culture and like
I don't know I just felt like she was
like such a party girl and that's kind
of what I am like I I basically just
party and sleep around and network and
of course my ultimate goal
and life has been to be famous and have
my own reality show and I've you know
I've had there's negotiations going on
right now for my own potential show
um and I've gotten a lot of press
opportunities and other shows because of
my lifestyle so it's kind of like a
win-win my work is also happens to be
taboo and fascinating to the world and
like I'm happy to share my stories that
I like legally can
um yeah I love it I love that my life's
interesting and I didn't even purposely
try and make it that way you did you did
good for a young man from the cornfields
of Indiana no literally cornfields to
the hills what's the hardest part of
this lifestyle for you
um
I guess the whole like The Kinks is hard
again I two different things like with
the whole like so basically most of the
time like when I meet a sugar daddy when
I call them a sugar daddy they're my
sugar I'm their sugar baby that's
because we've
um started out on like an escorting
basis you know with me we do what we did
I got paid and left but then once they
start reoccurring a lot then you know I
was like let's go to dinner let's turn
into a regular sugar daddy yeah and then
it becomes a lot more emotional and that
I feel like the emotional part is really
hard for me
um
because they're I'm not infatu I'm
infatuated with their money I'm not
actually I tell them you know straight
to their face it's not like
I hide it I'm like you have a lot more
feelings for me than I do emotionally
and I don't know sometimes it's it's
really draining
um to just pretend you care for a while
like for a long period of time if that
makes sense
I would say that's the hardest part it's
just very exhausting and draining and
like
um I did well in school like I could go
to college and stuff like that
um but I find that
I don't know I could get like a typical
nine to five even though it's like
everything I'm like basically against so
just I'm not against the nine to five
like I just don't want that for my life
but being a sugar baby ironically enough
is like a 24 7 job like there's a you
know it sounds like you're making too
much money to go to Starbucks and get a
job right oh yeah no for sure that too
but also just the whole like uh I don't
know it's it is a full-time job but you
do make great money and it's rewarding
but it's also risky and you do have to
be careful you know especially being
young
um especially getting flown out like
I've had people fly me out I don't know
what they look like I I don't know I'm
just like a big risk taker I'd rather
uh die young than
be old and die and have like like
nothing to really like talk about I
don't know like have not had like an
interesting life yeah regressive not
doing anything yeah did you did you have
goals or dreams of doing something other
than sex work
um I mean I am into body modifications
so I definitely like when I was in high
school I'm like I'm gonna be a plastic
surgeon
um and I could always do that you know
but um I like getting surgery done on me
more I think you've carved out the
perfect lifestyle for your personality
I'm trying to find a rich plastic
surgeon that's sugar daddy that's the
goal so obviously when I'm watching this
what advice would you give to somebody
who's watching this thinking that
something like this might work for them
um be smart with your money something I
a comment I get all the time from like
shows that I've done specifically ones
where I like show off everything I own
people in the comment there's always
like two sides it's always like oh he's
spending all of his money he's gonna age
and he's gonna be like homeless you know
and
in 15 years or whatever because he
overspends and then some of them are
like oh he's trying to flex these things
that he has but like obviously or how do
I explain this he's trying to flex all
of these things but they don't seem to
add up to millions of dollars and stuff
like that so it's like people are either
saying I'm spending too much or I'm
broke and I'm just saying this for show
and again you when you're filming you
basically only see like
I guess like breaking the fourth wall is
kind of the thing like you don't see
everything in my life
um and I'm smart with my money like I I
buy what I like but I also realize
unfortunately looks do Fade see the
reality is that you actually are saving
money yes being responsible with it very
well I wouldn't say very but I am like
one too yeah yeah that's my excuse to
myself I'm like oh I'm young I'm glad
for Botox because I feel like that will
help me looking younger longer and also
another
tip I would say is
again everyone's different but in I
guess specifically because of my body
type and just kind of my
yeah my body type
um people like me to look as young as I
can like they love it if I was underage
so like I feel like I put a lot of
pressure to always look younger on
myself
um which sometimes I feel like filler
and stuff makes me look older but I
don't know I'm just hoping it prevents
wrinkles so you think you could be more
marketable as a
17 16 year old one thousand percent a
lot of role play that I have to do with
guys is
like what I actually don't I actually
don't want to talk about that because
it's like yeah
but being younger is better yeah younger
is better yeah for sure how do you deal
with all the hate you must get a lot of
hate like on social media yeah I do
um it sounds like the comments you've
described sounds like they're they're
already just assuming that you're
irresponsible and doing terrible things
with your money and with your health and
yeah everything else
um I feel like a lot yeah I mean I get a
ton of hate but I also sometimes do feel
like
um
I am so nice fortunate that I did grow
up in the midwest because
I grew up in such a different lifestyle
and culture than like La so like in a
way I
it doesn't affect me that much because
that's what I like grew up with was like
you know I don't know how to explain it
like most of the time and people giving
me hate are
typically just like
not super westernized La culture people
if that might I'm like so bad at
explaining things
um so like I kind of understand their
mentality and where they're coming from
so it doesn't affect me that much and
also at a point you just get so numb to
things it's just like it becomes iconic
at that point like in my apartment I
literally have a wall it's probably bad
for my mental health of just hate
comments that I think are like funny
that I've gotten of myself so it's good
ever
an understanding that the social media
is just full of hate exactly
and I think that's because I'm so secure
in myself like I don't know I just think
it's iconic and I feel like also if
you're not getting hate you're not doing
something anything right
that's how I feel I think there's some
truth to that yeah
but I do understand people's concern
about
um
I do understand people's concern about
you know maybe my health
um because you do have to be very
careful about that
um I'm I've been very careful you know
with
having sex and stuff like that and so
far like everything's been good for me
and it's scary because it really only
takes that one person and you know
you're kind of [ __ ] so that's another
reason I have to be smart with my money
is because you know like something could
happen you could get an STD or something
that's incurable and I don't know it
would it would just definitely change
your life so you have to be careful
where would you like to be in five years
I definitely want to buy a house in five
years
um I know right now a house I would love
to I don't know marriage is like not
really a thing but I do would like to
have a boyfriend who never had a
boyfriend like my age
um I would still like to be a sugar baby
I mean I get so many crazy opportunities
that people my age like don't get for
sometimes ever like traveling and I know
I just so honestly living the same life
but just more money social media like
like Instagram I think is probably the
ultimate marketing tool for somebody
like you right yeah and that is I
completely forgot to even talk about
that there are women in small towns and
all over the world who have tapped into
that yeah it's social media has been our
traveling the world perhaps yeah making
tons of money right you can like make
money off of social media and which is
what I was doing too like obviously
being a sugar baby having only fans and
making money on social media with like
brand deals and stuff but because I get
so much hate my Instagram and Tick Tock
just got deleted it was back in June
and that's been hard for me because your
Instagram and Tick Tock accounts were
deleted same week same week and was
there something you posted that was
particularly no that's the thing like
again I'm like pretty smart like
obviously I post [ __ ] things I guess
you could say but like nothing like
actually showing or out of any capacity
and
again I just think it comes from I did
go on like a popular daytime TV show
right before that happened
so
um
I think just like the influx of people
coming from that video and just
reporting my accounts at the same time
is what caused it to get deleted but
that's been hard because again like I
felt like I built such a good following
and fan base and platform and then it
literally got taken away overnight and
that was like Wow real life no not being
glued to my phone all the time and it's
been nice but yeah that's been really
hard actually do you have any regrets
uh I'm I'm about like social media about
just your life your lifestyle what
you've done
with your life
I mean I've regretted meeting a few
people just because of some things that
have happened
um but I don't really regret like
no I really don't regret much honestly
again if something traumatic and maybe
this is just my way of coping with
trauma but if something traumatic
happens I'm very much like iconic like I
don't know and you seem to roll with it
very very well yeah
and Gary what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
most important lesson and you're 21
years
this is going to be such a shallow
statement so I don't know if I but truly
what I want to say is money equals
freedom
in my head I felt like
um
because of getting money and stuff I was
able to be free and live the life that I
wanted to
um but I feel like that's so shallow
because
yeah
um
just be smart I don't know like really
be smart like you can't be like people
look at me and like oh he's little
blondes like dumb blonde
um but I have to be smart obviously
um
yeah that's pretty good for 21. yeah
live fast Die Young that's like
wrestling yeah I understand that all
right Gary thank you so much for sharing
your story of course
thank you very much